welcome to data science interview
questions my name is Richard Kirchner
with the simply learned team that's w w
simply learned comm get certified get
ahead before we dive in and start going
through the questions one at a time
we're gonna start with some of the
logical kind of concept that's enters in
a lot of interviews and this one you
have two buckets one of three liters and
the other of five liters you're expected
to measure exactly four liters how will
you complete the task and no you only
have the two buckets you don't have a
third bucket or anything like that just
the two buckets and the object of the
question like this is to see how well
you are thinking outside the box in this
case here in a larger box you have two
buckets and also the pattern which
should go on and what that means is if
you look at the two buckets and we'll
show you their answer in just a second
you have a bucket with three litres and
a bucket with five litres and the first
thought is what happens if you go from
left to right so we have a direction and
what happens we pour the three litres
into the five litre bucket well if you
pour the three litres into five liter
bucket you have an empty bucket of three
litres and what's really important here
is thinking outside the box you realize
that you have a five liter bucket that
has three litres in it and two empty
litres
so you have two additional leaders you
can fill up if we continue that process
we can compare from the left to right
from the small bucket to the large
bucket you can now measure in two
additional liters into the five litre
bucket and three minus two is one and
you can keep doing that you can empty
the five litre bucket in pour those
three litres in that one liter in and
then you can pour three litres in what's
cool about these questions as you
explore them as you realize there's
multiple ways usually to solve I went
from small bucket to big bucket the
simply learned team their solution that
they pulled out was you fill the five
liter bucket and empty it into the three
liter bucket now you're left with two
liters in the five liter bucket so
that's great we can empty the three
liter bucket so now we're going from
large to small number we went from small
to large so you can go both either way
but you have to go one way or the other
it turns out and you can empty the three
liter bucket and pour the contents of
the five liter bucket in it so the three
liter bucket now has two liters and if
it has two liters that means it has an
empty 1 liter and by now you probably
have guessed that if you have an empty
space you can start using that empty
space of one liter as a measuring so we
fill the five liter bucket again
and we pour the water in the three litre
bucket it already has the two liters and
so we're only pouring one liter in there
and 5 minus 1 is 4 so interview
questions they break up into all kinds
of different patterns we have logic like
this one which is a lot of fun we have
questions that come up that are more
vocabulary list the difference between
supervised and unsupervised learning
probably one of the fundamental
breakdowns in data science and
supervised learning uses no one in label
data as input supervised learning has a
feedback mechanism most commonly used
supervised learning algorithms are
decision tree logistic regression
support vector machine and you should
know that those are probably the most
common use right now and there certainly
are so many coming out so that's a very
evolving thing and be aware of a lot of
the different algorithms that are out
there outside of the deep learning it's
a lot of these work faster on raw data
and numbers than they do then a deep
neural network would unsupervised
learning uses unlabeled data as input
unsupervised learning has no feedback
mechanism most commonly used
unsupervised learning algorithms are
k-means clustering hierarchical
clustering the approach a log algorithm
and there certainly are more I'm gonna
say k-means definitely is at the top of
list and the hierarchical clustering
those two are used so many times so
really important to understand what
those are and how they're used and most
important is understand that supervised
learning is you have your data set where
you have training data and you have all
those different pieces moving around but
you you're able to train it you know the
answers and unsupervised we're just
grouping things together that looked
like they go together
how is logistic regression done logistic
regression measures the relationship
between the dependent variable our label
what we want to predict and the one or
more independent variables are features
by estimating probability using its
underlying logistic function sigmoid and
whenever I draw these charts I always
end up drawing them the right-hand side
first because you want to know what your
output is what is he one out of here in
the left-hand side what do you have
going in you have your in and out you
can see we have a nice labeled image
here to help you remember this we have
our inputs we have our linear model we
have our probabilities what are the
probabilities of it being a certain way
based on these features coming in the
sigmoid function and it's important to
note that the sigmoid function is maybe
the most common
but it's only one of a number of
functions that are out there and the
sigmoid function turns our probabilities
into a value between 0 & 1 or very close
to 0 very close to 1 between point 1 and
point 0 9 and based on that we generate
an answer in this case is 0 or 1
how is logistic regression done so last
time we talked about the sigmoid
function generally depending on what's
your interview and level of math and
what expertise you're going in for the
market you'll have to understand that
formula of the probability equals 1 over
1 plus e to the negative y and that's e
to the base 2 so you have your
probability function or your sigmoid
function which pushes it as you can see
we have a nice visual of that and it's
that helps a lot to have that visual on
the sigmoid function you definitely
should know your y equals M times X plus
C your basic Lydian geometry of forming
a line in the slope plus the intercept
the y intercept and then you have your
natural log and the natural log is to
the e as opposed to a base 2 or base 10
it's your natural log to the e of the
probability over 1 minus a probability
equals your M times X plus C or your
Euclidean line that helps a lot as far
as the graphing and understanding the
sigmoid function so we'll just keep
pushing on to question number 3 explain
the steps in making a decision tree and
I noticed last time we brought up the
decision tree and the forest a lot of
questions came up what is the difference
so let's go through that when you make a
decision tree you're gonna take the
entire data set as input you're gonna
calculate entropy of the target variable
as well as the predictor attributes
I remembered entropy is just how chaotic
is it so if you have like you know
banana and grapes and oranges if you're
mixing in fruit and that's your data
coming in you have all these different
objects that are so separate from each
other and the more they become uniform
the lower the entropy and we call that
information gain so we gain information
on sorting different objects from each
other so you have your entropy you have
to calculate your information gain of
all attributes and then you choose the
attribute with the highest information
gain as the root node so if you can
separate your group and each group chaos
and each group is lowered whichever
split lowers a chaos the most that's
where you split it and that's your root
node at that point you repeat the same
procedure on every branch till the
decision node of each branch final
so understanding that setup is pretty
important as far as decision trees and
you can see here we have a nice visual
of decision tree for example if you want
to build a decision tree to decide
whether we should accept or decline a
job offer since these are interview
questions that's a good one to ask and
just as a tip you should be pretty aware
of the formula for entropy and
information gains you need to look those
up if you don't remember those in the
salary if it's greater than fifty
thousand no decline the off yes it's got
a good salary the commute is greater
than an hour yes decline the offer no
offers incentives yes accept the offer
no incentives decline the offer so we
use decision tree pretty much for
everything if you want and if you have a
decision tree then you also should
understand how do you build a random
forest model and remember that a random
forest is build up of a number of
decision trees so if you split your data
up into a lot of different packages and
you do a decision tree in each of those
different groups of data the random
forest is bringing all those trees
together so how do you build a random
forest model randomly select K features
from a total of M features where K is
less than M among the key features
calculate the node D using the best
split point split the node into daughter
nodes using the best split repeat steps
two and three steps until leaf nodes are
finalized build forest by repeating
steps one two four four in number times
to create n number of trees so you can
see it's got the same build pattern as
the tree but instead you're building a
number of different trees little small
trees so it all have an N leaf node
random forest has a vote at the end and
whoever gets the most votes wins that's
the answer how can you avoid overfitting
of your model very important question in
any kind of mathematical scientific data
science setup in any of them there are
three main methods to avoid overfitting
and you should really understand
overfitting overfitting means that your
model is only set for a very small
amount of data and ignores the bigger
picture keep the model simple take into
account fewer variables thereby removing
some of the noise and the training data
good advice for any programming at all
use cross-validation techniques such as
K folds cross-validation use
regularization techniques such as lasso
that penalize certain model parameters
if they're likely to cause overfitting
and you should also be well aware that
you
cross-validation techniques that's like
a pre-data or your lasso and your
regularization techniques are usually
during the process so when you're
prepping your data that's when you do a
cross-validation such as like splitting
your data into three groups and you
train it on two groups and test it on
one and then switch which two groups you
test it on that kind of thing so can you
solve up another one of these I love
these things there are nine balls out of
which one ball is heavy in weight and
the rest are of the same weight in how
many minimum weighings will you find the
heavier ball and when we're say weighing
think of a scale where you can put
objects on one side and the other and
you can see which side is heavier and
you want to minimize that you want to
split the balls up in such a way that
you're gonna do as few measurements as
you can you will need to perform two
Wang's
so you get it down to just two Wang's
and I always think if there's nine balls
I'm gonna divide them into three groups
of three place three balls on each side
so you can just randomly pick six of the
balls and three on one side three on the
other and if they balance out both sides
are equal then you know the heavyweight
isn't in any of those so out of the
remaining three balls from step one take
two balls and place one ball on each
side a little tricky there cuz I always
want to put all three you want to put
two on one side and one on the other but
no just take randomly pick two of those
put one on each side if they balance out
then the left out ball the one you
didn't measure will be the heavier one
otherwise you'll see it in the balance
you'll see which one's heavier because
you'll take one of the balls down now we
go to scenario B where they did not
balance out so now we know which side
has a heavier ball in it and it's just
very similar to what we did before if
the ball is in step one do not balance
out then take those three balls that
have the heavier side on them and
reproduce step two to find out the
heavier ball difference between
univariate bivariate and multivariate
analysis and hopefully if you know a
little Latin he'll kick in there that
you have unis and you have bi and you
have multi because the answer is in the
words themselves so the first one this
type of data contains only one variable
so that's the univariate purpose of the
univariate analysis is to describe the
data and find patterns exist within it
so when you only see one one variable
coming in in this case we're using
height of students you're limited as far
as what you can do with that data so you
can come up and
different patterns and conclusions from
those patterns using the means the
median the mode dispersion range minimum
maximum so we're describing the data so
all those words would describe the data
and that's about all you can do with
them data like that there's no
correlation there's nothing to go beyond
that as far as guessing or predicting
anything so we move into bivariate you
know uni means one bi means two
bivariate this type of data involves two
different variables the analysis of this
type of data deals with causes and
relationships and the analysis is done
to find out the relationship among the
two variables and this is always a
favorite one because everybody loves ice
cream in the summer when it's hot and
very few people go for ice cream in the
winter when it's really cold so it's
easy to see the correlation in the data
the temperature and ice cream cells in
summer season and you can see here where
the temperature goes from 28 to 35 and
as the temperature goes up so does the
sales of ice cream it goes from mm I'm
not sure mm what so I'm guessing it's a
very large chain because if they're
selling 2,000 ice cream cones and they
have a lot of business good for them
yellow vendor on the corner selling
2,000 ice cream cones a day and 3100 the
next day here the relationship is
visible from the table that temperature
and cells are directly proportional to
each other so the hotter the temperature
we can predict an increase in sales so
the word prediction should come up so we
have description and prediction when the
data involves three or more variables it
is categorized under multi variate it is
similar to bivariate but contains more
than one dependent variable in this
example another really common one the
data for house price prediction the
patterns can be studied by drawing
conclusions using mean median and mode
dispersion or range minimum maximum etc
and so you can start describing the data
that's what all that was and then using
that description to guess what the price
is gonna be so if this is very good if
you're in the market and you have
already looked at the area and you
already know that a 2-bedroom zero floor
900 square foot house is usually runs
about forty thousand you can guess what
the next one that looks similar to it is
and I'll just throw in another word in
there I don't see very often unless
you're really a hardcore data science we
talked about describing the data
descriptive we talked about predictive
and there's also post scriptum
PostScript Avene we're going to change
the very
to try to guess what the outcome is if
we change what's going on so that would
be the next step but that's usually
doesn't show up unless you're dealing
with some really hardcore data science
groups what are the feature selection
methods to select the right variables
there are two main methods for feature
selection
there's filter methods and wrapper
methods and when you're filtering your
before we discuss the two methods real
quick the best analogy for selecting
features is bad data in bad answer out
so when we're limiting or selecting our
features it's all about cleaning up the
data coming in so it's cleaner and was
more representative of what we're trying
to predict filter method filter methods
as they come in we have linear
discrimination analysis a nova chai
squared try square is probably the most
common one and these are all part of
pre-processing we're taking out all the
outliers all the things that have a
difference that is very different from
the data we're looking at the odd ones
and sometimes you take the odd ones out
and then you analyze them separately to
see why they're odd but remember your
filter methods you want to pull all that
weird stuff out wrapper methods on the
other hand our forward selection
backward selection recursive feature
elimination and one of the most
important things to remember about
wrapper methods is they're very
labor-intensive you have to have some
pretty high-end computers if you're
doing a lot of data analysis with the
wrapper method and just quickly forward
selection means you have all your
different features there off to the side
and we test just one feature at a time
we keep adding them in until we get a
good fit backward is we have all the
features and we start we run a test on
that to see how well it does and then we
start removing features to see what
works and recursive which is the most
processing hungry algorithm out there
goes through and just recursively looks
through all the different features and
how they pair together but again we have
filter method and wrapper method and
it's important to understand that we're
sorting the data out and finding out
which features are gonna represent the
data the best and which ones are not
gonna really add any value to our models
let's jump number 8 in your choice of
language write a program that prints the
numbers from 1 to 50 but for multiples
of 3 print fizz instead of the number
and for the multiples of 5 print a buzz
for numbers which are multiples of both
3 and 5 print fizz
buzz and this really is testing your
knowledge in iterating over data very
important my sister who runs the
university the data science team is in
charge of their department it's the
first question she asks in her interview
of anybody who comes in is how do they
iterate through data so if this question
comes up a lot and it's very important
you have an understanding
and there's actually a slight error on
this code which I'll point out in just a
second the concept is we have fizzbuzz
in range you have range 51 which in this
case goes from zero to fifty one and I'm
gonna challenge you to see if you can
catch the error and I'll tell you at the
end of the code where the error is what
that means is that we're gonna go
through all the numbers zero one two
three four and we're gonna process
through this loop if the remainder
fizzbuzz divided by three equals zero
and fizzbuzz divided by five also equals
zero then print fizzbuzz continue and
LCIF fizzbuzz divided by three equals
zero in print fizz print fizz continue
else if fizzbuzz divided by five equals
zero print buzz continued in print fizz
buzz you fit the print the answer in
this case fizzbuzz is either gonna be
the number we generated which is zero or
it will be the fizzbuzz fizz or buzz
whoo that's a mouthful now if you didn't
catch the error in the code which is
always a fun game find the error it has
to do with the range and it's important
to remember the range here says range
251 at 0 251 which is it's correct we
want to go to 51 because it stops it
gets to 50 and it stops so that's 0 to
50 but if you remember the question
asked from 1 to 50 so the range should
be 1 comma 51 not just 51 which does 0
to 51 in this particular script in
Python you could leave out that continue
but the continue in this script skips
the next else F so it doesn't keep
processing it going down and in
programming a lot of scripts you don't
need the continue answers would depend
on what script you chose and there's
probably some other ways to do this
that's a lot of fun and you can see here
from the output we end up with fizzbuzz
4 0 which shouldn't be there 1 2 fizz
for buzz fizz 7/8 fizzbuzz 11 fizz and
so on sounds like a drinking game from
my college days so long ago many decades
ago you are given a data set consisting
of variables having more than 30%
missing values how will you deal with
them oh the joy of messy data coming in
ways to handle missing data values data
set is huge we can just simply remove
the rows with missing data values is the
quickest way ie we use the rest of the
data to predict the values you just go
in there and say any row of our data
that has a n/a in it get rid of it that
doesn't work with smaller data so a
smaller data you start running into
problems because you lose a lot of data
and so we can substitute missing values
with the mean or average of the rest of
the data using pandas dataframe and
python there's different ways to do this
obviously in different languages and
even in Python there's different ways to
do this but in Python it's real easy you
can do the D F dot mean so you get the
mean value so if you set mean equal to
that then you can do a dfdl na with the
mean value very easy to do in a Python
pandas script and if you're using Python
you should really know pandas and dumpy
number Python and pandas dataframes
for the given points how will you
calculate the Euclidean distance in
Python so back to our basic algebra from
high school Euclidean distance is the
line on the triangle and so if we're
given the points plot 1 equals 1 comma 3
plot 2 equals 2 comma 5 we know that
from this we can take the difference of
each one of those points square them and
then take the square root of everything
so the Euclidean distance equals the
square root of plot 1 0 minus plot 2 is
0 squared plus plus 1 of 1 minus plot 2
of 1 squared mouthful there and you can
remember if you have multiple dimensions
and go past two dimensions you could
have plot 3 can simply be the distance
from plot 1 you'll need to do one side
of that ordered plot we can do either
way and square that and take the square
root of that
another Mindbender how to calculate
something how to figure out the solution
to something what is the angle between
the hour and minute hands of a clock
when the time is half past 6 so you want
to kind of imagine that clock where the
large hand is pointed down to the 30 and
the other half is gonna be right between
the 6 and the 7 because it's half-past
six there's actually a couple ways to
solve this but let's take a look and see
how they did it note a clock is a
complete circle having three
sixty degrees in one hour the hour hand
covers 360 over 12 so it equals 30
degrees for each hour in one minute the
minute hand covers 360 degrees over 60
minutes or six degrees per minute the
minute hand has traveled for 30 minutes
so it has covered 30 times six which
equals 180 degrees so we know that's 180
degrees from the 12 the hour hand has
traveled for 6.5 hours six and a half
six point five so it's covered six point
five times thirty which equals 195
degrees the difference between the two
will give the angle between the two
hands
thus the required angle equals 195 minus
180 equals 15 degrees and this is nice
the way they solved it because you can
now punch in any kind of time within
reason the hard part is on the hours is
you have to be able to convert the hours
into decimals explain dementia allottee
reduction and list its benefits
dimension reduction refers to the
process of converting a set of data
having vast dimensions into data with
lesser dimensions fills to convey
similar information concisely it helps
in data compressing and reducing the
storage space it reduces computation
time as less dimensions lead to less
computing it removes redundant features
for example there's no point in storing
a value in two different uterine units
meters and inches and I certainly rented
a lot with this with text analysis I've
been known to run a text analysis over a
series of documents ends up with over
1.4 million different features that's a
lot of different words being used and if
you do what they call by connect them
you connect two words together now
you're up to 4.8 million different
features and you start having to figure
ways to bring that down what can we get
rid of that kind of thing so you can see
where that can get really high in on
processing and learning how to reduce
the list dimensions is very important
how will you calculate eigenvalues and
eigenvectors of a 3x3 matrix and what
they're really looking for here is when
you write it out for the eigen is that
you know that you're gonna use the
lambda that's the most common one
obviously can use any symbol you want
but lambdas usually what they use and
that you do it down the middle diagonal
and so when you take that matrix and you
take the characteristic
equation end up with the determinant and
that's the -2 minus lambda minus 4 2
minus 2 1 minus lambda 2 4 2 5 minus
lambda and that's what they're looking
for and you know that's equal to 0 so
when you're doing a matrix in the eigen
setup with the eigenvectors that's all
going to come out equal to 0 and then
you can go ahead and write the whole
equation out so we can expand the
determinant 1 so you can see right here
the minus 2 minus lambda times it's a
mouthful I'll leave it up here for a
second so you can look at it when you
break it down into the algebraic
functions you end up with minus lambda
cubed plus 4 lambda squared plus 27
lambda minus 90 equals 0 so now we have
a nice algebraic equation built from the
eigenvectors and always remember you can
hit the pause button and you can also
send a note send a note to simply learn
if you have more questions on vectors or
on this definitely you have that
resource available to you or post down
in the low on the YouTube video comments
and so when we calculate the eigen
values and eigen vectors of a 3 by 3
matrix as we continue on down the math
of this and to be honest I really don't
like working with matrixes like this
it's important to understand the math
behind it and it's important to know the
code just enough so that you're not lost
when someone's explaining it or it comes
up and I'm working on different data
science models of course if you're
dealing with a high end math side of it
then you better know this first is by
hitting trial so you try you in
different variables to solve for 0 and
you can come in here and you'll find
that if we put in the 3 in there we end
up with a 0 at the end and substitute
the 3 hence we end up with lambda minus
3 is one of the factors and you can do
the math going out on that where we have
lambda cubed minus 4 lambda squared - 27
lambda plus 90 equals lambda minus 3
times lambda squared minus lambda minus
30 so eigen values based on that one our
3 minus 5 and 6 and then from there we
can calculate the eigenvector for lambda
equals 3 and you can see here where the
matrix is we write it out as the -5 - 4
- - - - - - - 4 - 2 that's from the
beginning put it in the XY and z equals
0 0 0 and so when we put in those
numbers and we calculate them out we
have 4x equals 1 we have the
- five minus 4y plus 2z equals zero
minus two minus 2y plus 2z equals zero
and subtracting the two equations we
just had we get three plus 2y equals
zero y equals minus three over two and Z
equals a minus one over two that's going
back to the first equation and similarly
we can calculate the eigenvectors for
minus five and six how should you
maintain your deployed model ooh
distribution time my favorite I spent 10
years in software distribution so first
thing and this is true not just of your
data science model but of any computer
code going out there's this basic set up
can work although usually there's a
little added steps in there first we're
going to monitor it so we have a
constant monitoring of all the model is
needed to determine the performance
accuracy of the models so yeah we want
to keep an eye on it we want to make
sure they're accurate we want to make
sure that whatever they're supposed to
predict or I threw in that bonus word
post script where you change something
you want to figure out how your changes
are going to affect things we need to
monitor it and make sure it's doing what
it's supposed to do evaluation metrics
of the current model is calculated to
determine if new algorithm is needed and
then we compare it the new models are
compared against each other determine
which model performs the best and then
we do a rebuild the best performing
model is rebuilt on the current state of
data this is interesting I found this
out just recently if you're in weather
prediction the really big weather areas
have about seven or eight different
models depending on what's going on and
so you actually have almost a distal
forest going on there where they're like
which model is gonna fit best and this
is what we're gonna use to predict the
weather with so not only do you don't
necessarily get rid of the models but
you figure out which models fit data of
what's going on or the current state of
data what our recommender systems most
commonly used nowadays in marketing so
very big industry understanding
recommender systems predicts the rating
or preference a user would give to a
product and they're split into two
different areas one is collaborative
filtering and a good example of that is
the last mmm recommends tracks that are
often played by other users with similar
interests so people who if you're on
Amazon people who bought this also
bought that this got me a few times and
then there's contact based filtering and
we're looking at content instead of
looking at who else is listening to the
music Lee's example Pandora which uses
the properties of a song to recommend
music with similar properties so you
have collaborative filtering and
content-based filtering how to find rmse
and MSE in linear regression model
hopefully you remember what the - an
acronym mean because that is like half
the answer we have the root mean square
error and the mean square error and
linear regression model so we're looking
for error
the our MSE and the MSE are the two of
the most common measures of accuracy for
a linear regression model and you can
see here we have the root mean square
error RMS C equals and this is the
square root of the sum of the predicted
- the actual squared over the total
number so we're just looking for the
average mean so we're looking for the
average over the N and the reason you
need to know about there between RMS C
versus MSE is when you're doing a lot of
these models and you're building your
own model why do you need to take the
square root of it it doesn't change the
value as far as the way you're using it
because you're looking to us to see
whether the error is greater or less
than so why I add that extra computation
in so a lot of models use the MSE which
indicates the mean square error or the
average error and it's the same formula
minus the square root at the end or
across the whole thing
another riddle to solve if it rains on
Saturday with a probability of 0.6 and
it rains on Sunday with the probability
0.2 what is the probability that
arraigns this weekend and the trick in
probabilities on this case is we're not
we need to know what is the probability
of it not raining was it not what's the
chance of it not raining on Saturday and
if it doesn't rain on Saturday we want
to take that and combine that with the
chance of it not raining on Sunday the
total probability which in this case
we're just gonna use 1 minus the
probability that it will not rain on
Saturday so that's 1 minus 0.6 we're
gonna take that as a Union which we
simply just multiply them together of
the probability they will not rain on
Sunday and it's important to recognize
the union here or the and you can see by
the formula down here we end up with
0.68 or 68 percent chance that it will
rain on the weekend and there are a
couple other ways to solve this but this
is probably the most traditional way of
do
that how can you select k4k means so
first you better understand that what K
means is
and that K is a number of different
groupings and most commonly we use is
the elbow method to select K for K means
the idea the elbow method is to run
k-means clustering on the data set where
K is a number of clusters within the sum
of squares WS s is defined as a sum of
the squared distance between each member
of the cluster and its centroid and you
should know all the terms for your
k-means on there and with the elbow
point and again here's our iteration in
our code we talked about that earlier
you iterate starting with usually don't
start right at 1 but you might start
with two three or four now you just see
where it comes out and you can see the
nice elbow there which is easy to see
graphically where the number of K
clusters and the WS s value drops and
then it just kind of flattens out
there's no reason to take the k-means
any further what is the significance of
p value oh good one especially if you're
dealing with r cuz that's the first
thing that pops up p value typically
less than or equal to 0.05 indicates a
strong evidence against the null
hypothesis and you should know what a
difference why we use null hypothesis
instead of the hypothesis so you reject
the null hypothesis very important that
term null hypothesis in any scientific
setup and also in data science it
doesn't mean that it's true it means
that there's a high correlation that
it's true so if your nor hypothesis
means it's not true your hypothesis is
as a high correlation that it's probably
true and if the p-value is typically
greater than 0.05 it indicates a weak
evidence against the null hypothesis so
you fail to reject the whole null
hypothesis and if you reject that then
your actual hypothesis is probably not
true the correlation of your data with
what you think it's saying is is
probably incorrect and if you're right
at the cutoff 0.05 it's considered to be
marginal could go either way and again
you can use that p-value on different
features to decide whether you're going
to include your features as far as
something worth exploring in your data
science model
how can outlier values be treated oh
good one you can drop outliers only if
it is a garbage value so sometimes you
end up with like one out
that just is probably someone's
measurements way off height of an adult
equals ABC feet this cannot be true as
hike cannot be a string value in this
case outliers can be removed if the
outliers have extreme values they can be
removed for example if all the data
points are clustered between 0 to 10 but
one point lies at 100 then we can remove
this point and again sometimes you just
look for the outlier so you can see
what's going on if there's something
unusual there so maybe the equipment's
not calibrated correctly if you cannot
drop outliers you can try the following
try a different model data detected as
outliers by linear model can be fit by
nonlinear model so we be sure you are
choosing the right model so if it is
like more of a curve look to instead of
a straight line you might need to use
something other than just a straight
line linear model try normalizing the
data this way the extreme data points
are pulled to a similar range if you can
use algorithms which are less affected
by outliers example random forests so
there is another solution is you can
come up with the random forest which a
lot of times completely bypasses your
outliers how can you say that a time
series data is stationary oh that's an
interesting term stationary meaning it's
not moving but it's a time series we can
say that a time series a stationary when
the variance and mean of the series is
constant with time and this the graphic
example is very easy to see we have our
the variance is constant with time so we
have our first variable Y and X and X
being the time factor and Y being the
variable as you can see goes through the
same values all the time it's not
changing in the long period of time so
that's stationary and then you can see
in the second example the waves get
bigger and bigger so that's non
stationary here the variance is changing
with time again we have Y which stays
constant so that if you look at the
bigger picture it's the same wave over
and over again and then of course we
have where the wave is growing in size
going up it can also go down so it also
be non stationary how can you calculate
accuracy using confusion matrix oh great
one confusion matrixes are so useful
when you're taking that first look at
data and also when you're showing the
shareholders and he went ask him for
money how can you calculate accuracy
using confusion matrix so you have your
total data that we're looking at a 650
and you have your predicted values and
your
so values and your predicted P and your
actual P and so we look at this you'll
note that if the predicted P and the
actual P are 262 but our predicted P
also had 15 that weren't correct so you
can see there's a false positive there
are 15 and the same thing with the end
you can see we're in predicts in and it
has a false negative of 26 out of the
total number of n values in there and so
we can do an accuracy on there the true
positive plus the true negative is our
total observations so you have a total
of 0.9 three accuracy or 93 percent and
just a quick note on this this is so
important because it's one thing if
someone is being diagnosed with say
cancer you know this is life death or is
my nuclear reactor going to blow up
suddenly if the P is the probability of
it blowing up and this let's say you
have 15 that's a lot less than say the
26 chances of it blowing up you know so
the actual domain of your data is very
important so if your non positive you
don't really care about the predicted
value having non positive is positive
because they're gonna go do a biopsy on
the cancer or whatever anyway but you're
very interested if you have a positive
an actual positive value which is looked
at as negative a false negative that's
really important in that domain
depending on what domain you're in write
the equation and calculate precision and
recall rate and so continuing with our
confusion matrix I was just talking
about the different domains we have the
precision equals 262 over 277 so your
precision is the true positive over the
true positive plus false positive and
the recall rate is your true positive
over the total positive plus false
negative and you can see here we have
that 262 over 277 equals a 94% and the
recall over here is the 262 over 280
which equals nine point nine or ninety
percent and oh good we're gonna take a
pause for another brainteaser if a
drawer contains 12 red socks 16 blue
socks and 20 white socks how many must
pull out to be sure of having a matching
pair the last time I went through these
kind of brain teaser things was like 20
years ago and I had six people sitting
across the table waiting for my hand
sir that's kind of mind-numbing when
you're in an interview like that
hopefully you're not stuck in an
interview like that but on this you need
to ask yourself how many different
colors of socks are there so they've
thrown a lot of extra data in here that
you don't need to solve the answer the
answer is for an example your first pick
is white your second pick is red third
pick is blue so no pairs yet and that
means when you get to the fourth pick
there's a hundred percent chance they're
gonna have a match so that most is gonna
be four that you ever have to pull out
of your drawer if it was four colors the
answer would be five and so on it
doesn't matter how many white socks you
have or how many red socks are blue
socks different pairs you have it's two
different colors and number of different
colors people who bought this also
bought recommendations seen on Amazon as
a result of which algorithm we covered
this earlier recommendation engine is
done with collaborative filtering
collaborative filtering explains the
behavior of other users in their
purchase history in terms of ratings
selection etc that makes predictions on
what you might interest a person based
on the preference of many other users
and this algorithm features of the items
are not knowing and we have a nice
example here where they took a snapshot
of a sales page it says for example
suppose X number people buy a new phone
and then also buy tempered glass with it
next time when a person buys a phone
he'll be recommended to buy tempered
glass along with it and if you remember
the vocabulary words we covered earlier
this is the recommendation this is
collaborative the other word was
content-based so looking at things with
similar content versus collaborative
which is similar people I remember you
know you're not gonna know every
vocabulary word but it also doesn't hurt
to get your three by five cards out and
make yourself a vocabularies deck of
cards by an app on your phone for it
SQL query I remember back in the 90s it
was so important to know SQL query and
only a few people got it nowadays it's
just part of your kit you have to know
some basic SQL so write a basic SQL
query to list all orders with customer
information and you can kind of make up
your own name for the database and you
can posit here if you want to write that
down on a paper and let's go ahead and
look at this we have to list all orders
with customer information and so usually
you have an order table and a customer
table and you have
order ID a customer ID order number
total amount and then from your customer
table you have ID first name last name
city county and so if we're gonna write
in SQL with this we're going to select
keyword there for SQL selecting order
number total amount first name last name
city country so that's the columns we're
gonna look at we're gonna do that from
our order where we're gonna join it with
our customer and we're gonna join it on
the order customer ID equals the
customer ID so very basic SQL query
that's gonna return a table of data for
us you are given a dataset on cancer
detection you built a classification
model and achieve an accuracy of 96%
whoo 96% why shouldn't you be happy with
your model performance what can you do
about it
as an interesting one because this comes
up that's when the standard data sets on
there is for cancer detection cancer
detection results in imbalanced data in
an imbalanced data set accuracy should
not be based as a measure of performance
because it is important to focus on the
remaining 4% which are the people who
were wrongly diagnosed we talked a
little about this earlier you have to
know your domain you know this is the
medical cancer domain versus whether
domain you know whether a channel they
get by with 50% wrong in cancer you
don't want 4 percent of the people being
wrongly diagnosed wrong diagnosis is of
a major concern because there can be
people who have cancer but we're not
predicted so in an imbalance data set
accuracy should not be used as a
measurement performance which of the
following machine learning algorithm can
be used for inputting missing values of
both categorical and continuous
variables so we have a couple choices
here we have k-means clustering we have
linear regression we have the k in int
nearest neighbor and decision tree and
which of the following machine learning
algorithms can be used for inputting
missing values of both categorical and
continuous variables now certainly you
can use some pre-processing to do some
of that but you should have gone with
the K nearest neighbor because it can
compute the nearest neighbor and if it
doesn't have the value it just computes
a nearest neighbor based on all the
other features where when you're dealing
with k-means clustering or linear
regression you need to do that in your
pre-processing
otherwise they'll crash decision trees
also although there's some variance on
that too
can you solve another riddle always fun
one's given a box of matches and two
ropes not necessarily identical measure
a period of 45 minutes and in this
particular setup the ropes are not
uniform in nature and the rope takes
exactly 60 minutes to completely burn
out so each rope takes up to 60 minutes
to burn out and there's actually a
couple different solutions to this but
let me go ahead and one of the things is
they're not uniform in nature so even
though they take 60 minutes anyway so
let's go ahead and see what they did to
solve it and then we can also look at
different options we have two ropes a
and B light a from both ends
and B from one end okay when a is
finished burning we know that 30 minutes
have elapsed and B has 30 minutes
remaining now light the other end of B
also so that the remaining part of B
will burn taking 15 minutes to burn this
we have gotten 30 plus 15 equals 45
minutes excellent solution mine which I
like was to take one rope fold it in two
so we know it's a half-hour take the
other rope fold it in four places so we
know that that one's 15 minutes and then
you can just connect the two and burn it
straight across I think they're trying
to cover that by saying they're not
regular the ropes are have some
irregularities maybe that's what they
meant by that is you couldn't do
something like that that's my solution
below are the eight actual values of
target variable in the training file so
we have a training file and not to be
confused with the train on the tracks we
have 0 0 0 1 1 1 1 1 what is the entropy
of the target variable we mentioned
earlier that you should know your
entropy and how to calculate the entropy
what is the entropy of the target
variable so we have a couple options
here we have minus 5 over 8 logarithm of
5 over 8 plus 3 over 8 logarithm of 3
over 8 ok let's just see where they got
those numbers from we have 1 which is
going to be 5 ones and 3 zeros and then
we have a total of 8 okay and then we
have the option of 5 which is number
ones five eight logarithm of 5/8 plus
3/8 logarithm of 3/8 and we also have
three A's logarithm of 5/8 plus 5/8
logarithm of 3/8 and then we kind of
reverse those numbers around and let's
see what you're going to get here
one did you think it was you should
check the first one so what is the
entropy of the target variable the key
there is a target variable so we're
looking at the target in this case is
going to be one usually that's what
you're looking for and so the entropy of
that one we want to subtract out the
entropy of the non target variable
whoops I had that backwards we want to
take when he had zero so we want to
subtract out the 5/8 from there so 5/8
logarithm 5/8 or a negative 5/8
logarithm 5/8 plus 3/8 a logarithm 3/8
and they have the hint on the bottom
entropy equals I of P of n so we have a
negative P plus PN times the logarithm
base 2 of P over P plus n minus the N
over P plus n times the logarithm 2 of n
over P plus n we want to predict the
probability of death from heart disease
based on three risk factors age gender
and blood cholesterol level what is the
most appropriate algorithm for this case
so we have three features and we want to
know the predictability of death okay a
little morbid there choose the right
algorithm do we want to use logistic
regression for this linear regression
k-means clustering or the appropriate
algorithm and if you selected logistic
regression then you probably got the
right answer linear regression remember
deals with like you take your line and
draw a line through the data of course
you don't necessarily have to use a
straight line there's other means for
that but you're dealing with a lot of
numbers and k-means means we're just
gonna cluster objects together with the
logistic regression though you can mix
those things together in buckets
so really the logistic regression is
what you want to use in that model would
be the most apt fit after studying the
behavior of a population you have
identified four specific individual
types who are valuable to your study you
would like to find all users who are
most similar to each individual type
which algorithm is most appropriate for
this study
certainly identifying census in just
about a lot of different markets is
common so maybe they have a census or
whatever means but let's take a look at
some of the different algorithms we
might use on this we have k-means
clustering linear regression Association
rules and decision trees and I'll give
you a hint we're looking for grouping
people together by similarities and by
for different similarity so we're
specific they gave you one of the values
specifically the K value so k-means
clustering would be great for this
particular problem you have run the
Association rules algorithm on your data
set and the two rules banana
Apple is associated with grape and apple
orange is associated with grape have
been found to be relevant what else must
be true
so this attend you to understand
Association rules you could picture in
this particular one you're going
shopping and you almost always see
somebody who has bananas they usually
have grapes in their bag also and
somebody who has apples usually has
grapes in their bags and then apples and
oranges is also associated with grapes
and let's go ahead and take a look at
that and we have a couple different
options here first one is banana apple
and grape orange must be a frequent item
set not so much banana apples oranges
must be relevant rule grape is common
with banana Apple must be a relevant
rule and how about grape Apple must be a
frequent item set let's go back and take
a look at that and we notice that we
have bananas apples to grapes we have
apple orange to great boy there's a lot
of grapes and a lot of apples in there
and so if you said the last one grape
and Apple must be a frequent item set
then you got it correct your
organization has a website where
visitors randomly receive one of two
coupons it is also possible the visitors
to the website will not receive a coupon
you have been asked to determine if
offering a coupon to visitors to your
website has any impact on their purchase
decision which analysis method should
you use and so let's go ahead and start
by giving you another hint and give you
some limiting your selection we have a
one-way ANOVA k-means clustering
Association rules and student t-test so
obviously if you know what each one of
these means well let's take a look at
the question again so you want to know
which method should you use to see if
the coupons valid for their purchase
well we're not clustering and we're not
Association things together we want to
know the end result student t-test also
drawing that little T in boxes and
switch them around there's really only
one answer that works in here and that's
the one-way ANOVA so that draws us to an
end I want to thank you for joining us
today for more information visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor extras' will try
to reach out to you and answer those
questions again thank you for joining us
and happy learning and since these are
interview questions good luck on your
next interview or if your the interview
or looking for questions to ask people
good luck on your next interview
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here